Moderator: Get that started.
Moderator: Okay, so I have started the recording, and I would like to confirm, are you comfortable if I record my screen and audio as we talk today?
P09: Yes, that's fine.
Moderator: Okay, and are you comfortable if we decide to use a recorded clip from our discussion today to share with our VA partners if we remove any information that can be used to identify you?
P09: That's fine.
Moderator: Okay, thank you. So, before we jump into the prototype and start looking at that, we do have a couple of warm-up questions. So, first off, do you have a VA.gov account?
P09: Yes, I do.
Moderator: Okay, so how often are you logging into VA.gov, and for what type of task?
P09: I would say, like… Maybe a couple times a month, primarily for health.
Moderator: Okay.
P09: And I do have the app, and I, yeah, that's usually how I access it.
Moderator: Okay, thank you. And have you ever applied for the CHAMPVA program?
P09: I have done.
Moderator: Okay. Have you heard about the CHAMPVA program before?
P09: Yes, I have.
Moderator: Okay. And can you tell me a little bit about what you know of the program?
P09: It's a kind of, healthcare product offered to, family members of Veterans, I believe.
Moderator: Okay, so for today, we're going to talk a little bit about CHAMPVA, but let's say you just submitted a CHAMPVA application on VA.gov. What would you expect to happen after you submit your application?
P09: I would expect to receive an email or letter within a certain period of time, notifying me whether I do qualify or have… am, yeah, eligible for those benefits.
Moderator: And you said an email or a letter. Can you kind of expand on both of those options?
P09: I would normally expect an email, but I do notice that the VA tends to oftentimes, send you, like, formal letters, whether… when it has to do with benefits.
Moderator: Okay. And, you had also mentioned, what would you like to be notified about in your email or those letters?
P09: I'd like to notify whether I qualified for those benefits or not, and if I do, that it would give me detailed information as to my next steps in terms of using those benefits. And if I do not… if I'm not eligible, I would expect to hear what reasons I do not qualify.
Moderator: Okay.
Moderator: And how would you expect to find, various updates about your application?
P09: I would Perhaps, you know, either through the app or the website, see the status of the application, whether it's being reviewed or, maybe even have a timeline as far as when I should expect to hear a response.
Moderator: Okay, so you would check, to see status, but also, how soon do you expect to be notified about any updates on your application?
P09: Any updates, or you mean the actual final decision?
Moderator: Either.
P09: I mean, to be honest, I don't really expect to hear many updates from the VA as far as, applications of that sort, but as far as receiving a decision, maybe…A month.
Moderator: And… when you say a month, what is that, for… I guess, what is that timeline from?
P09: From the date of submission of the application.
Moderator: Okay, so you want to hear within a month of submitting your application. Okay.
Moderator: Okay, sounds good. So, I'm gonna… we're gonna jump into the prototype, so in a moment, I'm gonna drop a link into the chat, which I would like you to open up in your browser, and then I'm gonna have you share your screen in Zoom. So I can help you walk through that, but first, I wanna give you a moment to close any browser windows, tabs, or applications.
Moderator: And also silence notifications on your device, it just doesn't interfere. So, let me know when you are ready for the link.
P09: I'm ready for the link.
Moderator: Okay, and I would also like to confirm what type of device you are on today.
P09: I'm on an iPhone.
Moderator: Okay, perfect. So, let me know when you, get that open.
P09: Okay, it's now open, so should I share the screen?
Moderator: Yes, and if you could share your screen on your phone, please.
P09: Let's do this.
Moderator: Okay.
P09: You can see the screen?
Moderator: I see it now, yes.
Moderator: Okay, so now that you have a prototype up, I'm gonna go and walk you through a couple of scenarios today. I'm gonna have you give me feedback as you navigate through this prototype. On each page, I'm gonna ask that you kind of think out loud, so we can really just hear your honest opinions. Again, we want to improve these tools, and we're not testing your ability in any way.
Moderator: Okay. So, before we get started, do you have any questions?
P09: I do not.
Moderator: Okay.
Moderator: So, for this first scenario, I'd like you to imagine that you just submitted a CHAMPVA application recently for two family members. You have Jane Doe and John Doe Jr, and you want to find out what is happening with their application. So, you log in to VA.gov, and this is this upcoming screen is the first thing that you see.
Moderator: So, you can go ahead and click continue.
Moderator: And so, if you want to find out what is happening for your Champ VA application for Jane and John Doe, can you show me what you… can you kind of walk me through what you would do next? Like, I want you to take a moment to review this page and think out loud as you go, but just don't click on anything just yet. Okay.
Moderator: This page may look a little different than what you've seen before.
P09: Okay.
P09: I mean, the heading at the top is helpful, claim and application status. So, the in progress in the box stands out to me first, and so that immediately notifies me that both the applications represented by these two boxes, are in progress. So that's the first thing that I see, pops up.
P09: Below that, I see disability rating, so I assume that refers to me.
P09: Forms, in-progress forms, so this… it sounds like, in addition to whatever applications that I have for CHAMPVA, it actually has all the applications I've submitted for any sort of, benefits, here, along with Healthcare information, so this seems to be kind of like a one-stop Page for anything that's pending in all my current and, pending benefits that I have.
Moderator: Okay, so if you were to try and find the updated status of the application. What would you do?
P09: So I would click on check status details for either of these.
Moderator: Okay. You said for either of them?
P09: Yeah, so depending upon which one I wanted to find status on, I would just check status details. Now that you say that, I do notice that it does actually indicate the step that each application is at, so I didn't see that before, so step 2 of 5 is initial review for the first one, and then one of four is the other one.
Moderator: Okay, so you mentioned that you would click, or, yeah, that you would click check status details. What do you think would happen if you click on that link?
P09: That it would go maybe, more in-depth as to what this… Step is.
Moderator: Okay.
Moderator: Is there anything else that you would expect when you click that link?
P09: I mean, perhaps I might, give an estimated time of when… The decision will… Be made, or maybe, when the next step will come up.
Moderator: Okay.
Moderator: That's helpful. So, for right now, we'll zoom out a little bit, and I know you were kind of talking about this section as a whole a moment ago, but is this section where you would expect to find your applications?
P09: Based upon what you've told me, I thought I would only see the status of these two CHAMPVA applications. I didn't expect that it would indicate, or that it would present all other information regarding all other benefits that I have.
Moderator: Okay. So you kind of mentioned all of the other benefits. What would you expect to be in this section, then?
P09: I mean, if it was, a link that led to here, pointing me towards my CHAMPVA application status, I would have expected to only see information on the CHAMPVA, not necessarily the other things. Not that it's…
Moderator: I see.
P09: bad thing to receive the other information. I mean, it could be helpful as well, if I do have other pending applications to kind of see them, the status all at once. That would actually be convenient, as opposed to having to go to different pages for those things.
Moderator: I see, okay.
Moderator: And so, before we move on, you're already kind of here, I want you to kind of review this form section, and what do you expect to… to see here?
P09: Or… oh, this form section?
P09: Well, it does say in progress form, so any other forms I submitted for, VA benefits.
P09: I would expect those to pop up here, kind of like with the CHAMPVA, like, each box representing a different, application submission.
Moderator: Okay. And so, I'm also curious, what would you expect to find in the completed form section?
P09: Okay, so now I'm seeing…
P09: That there is a difference between… Well, I'm…
P09: I'll state what maybe, confused me a little bit, so…
P09: You have a heading up here where it says In Progress Forms, so that seems to be kind of like a super heading.
P09: So I wouldn't have expected to see, in gray, this drop-down menu with completed forms, because it seems like that's subsumed underneath, above in-progress forms, and so I guess that threw me off a little bit. So, I see that there is a distinction between in-progress forms and then clicking here, completed forms, things that I already have submitted, and then when I'm  clicking on this, I'm seeing that this does reflect the CHAMPVA forms that were submitted above, which also kind of throws me off a little bit, because I did see at the top that there were two CHAMPVA applications that were submitted, but under the completed form, that's the only one box for one of the forms.
Moderator: Okay, so I have a couple of quick follow-ups. So, at the top, you said that you felt as if there were two, two boxes, essentially, for CHAMPVA. Can you tell me a little bit more about that?
P09: Yeah, so there's a box at the top for each CHAMPVA form that was submitted.
P09: And so, when I'm looking down at completed forms, I thought that there would have been two separate boxes for each individual CHAMPVA application under the completed forms, given that both forms were essentially completed and submitted.
Moderator: Oh, okay.
P09: But here, there's only one, yep.
Moderator: Okay. And then, within this form section, you were kind of talking about, like, the size of in progress versus completed. I guess, what would you have liked to have seen?
P09: I mean, it's not a huge confusion, but… I…
P09: Didn't really notice the completed forms gray bar as much.
P09: And it is a little bit off to me that this section for completed forms is under the in-progress form. It looks like it's underneath the in-progress forms, so maybe if there was, more consistency, then you would have the same kind of…
P09: font and size and presentation of the words completed forms in the same manner that in-progress forms is actually written. And then that, too, would also have maybe a box below it to be… to have a little bit more consistency.
Moderator: Okay, I see. So it feels as if it's a subpart of in-progress forms versus it kind of having the same level or importance, as in-progress. Okay.
Moderator: And so, we've kind of talked about the two sections here, but how would you describe what the claims and application status section is for versus what the forms section is for?
P09: So the claims and application status would be once the forms have been submitted, at what stage they are in terms of the review. The completed forms would be all forms that were submitted, so they don't indicate any sort of status, it's just things that you've completed,
P09: Or, I'm sorry, we're talking about forms, so if it's in-progress forms, I actually noticed that it says draft, so it looks like the application for education benefits, was not completed, and so it's still under in progress. The completed forms would be all the forms that were submitted, and, their status would be found at the very top of the page.
Moderator: Okay.
Moderator: That's helpful. And so, what do you… what are your thoughts on the names of each of these sections?
P09: I think it's pretty… clear and intuitive.
P09: Maybe, in terms of position, it would make sense to have it closer to, or right below, claim and application status, the ones at the top, as opposed to having disability rating between the, between the two sections.
Moderator: Okay, that's helpful feedback, thank you. So, now that you've seen both sections, what would you do next if you were trying to check on the status of your application for CHAMPVA?
P09: I would click, I mean, I would look at the information in these boxes at the top, and then click Check Status Details, but I'm also noticing that it says below the two boxes, track claims, decisions, reviews, and applications, so I don't know if that's a redundancy, or if that's something different.
Moderator: Well, what would you think would happen if you clicked the Track Claims, Decision Reviews, and Applications link?
P09: I would guess that it would be the same information as what I find under check status details, perhaps.
Moderator: Okay, I see.
Moderator: So, okay, so you said that if you were to go check the status of your application, you would look at one of those two at the top. Which one would be the first one we decide to check?
P09: I would just go with whatever's at the top first.
Moderator: Okay.
Moderator: So, I will say, let's, for today, let's click the link in the application for CHAMPVA Benefits.
Moderator: So the check status details, we can go ahead and click that link.
P09: Right.
Moderator: Okay, so now that you've landed here, let's continue imagining that you're still trying to find out more information about your CHAMPVA application, and about what will happen next. So, take a moment to review this page, as well as the other tabs, and just, like, think out loud as you go.
P09: Okay, so, Oh, you know what, so I was a little bit confused earlier, because we were looking to CHAMPVA benefits, and so I thought that each… I thought that each box represented the two different CHAMPVA applications, but I'm noticing and realizing that this is actually just one application for both family members, so I didn't realize it was just a single application, so that was my confusion from earlier.
P09: That is what I'm looking for, so I am looking down. It says it's in progress.
P09: What you need to see, you don't need to do anything right now. If there's an update, we'll mail you a letter and let you know here what we're doing.
P09: Receive it, if we need more information, we'll mail you, okay?
P09: Exactly, your application moves step one, application received. I mean, looking at this, there doesn't seem to be that much more information here than what I would have found in the previous page in the box, and so it seems…mostly the same information, but I see that there's also a Files tab, so I'm going to see what's in here. If you need to update your information, this could be... So, this is giving me an opportunity to Upload supporting documents.
P09: As I'm looking at this, I'm wondering, how would I know, what I would need to update? If there was more information I needed to provide, would someone notify me of that?
P09: Or is it that when I submitted the application, I knew that I wasn't including certain files, and I'm just submitting it, and that I would add the files later, and this is where I would do that? But I do see that there's also Checkboxes for both people who would potentially receive benefits, so I can indicate who I want to upload documents for.
The last tab here, overview of the application process, track where you are in the application process for CHAMPVA benefits. This seems… well, I see there's actually… well, step one, the information seems like… a redundancy of what was given on the status tab, as well as the previous page, but I see that there's… it gives you a description of every step that you go through. So it seems like this is basically a guide of… or a glossary, or a kind of a…page that tells you what each step represents.
Moderator: Okay, so on this page, I know you kind of just walked through these.
Moderator: Can you tell me what happens to your application in each of these steps in your own words?
P09: Application received is self-explanatory. I just… whatever the application entailed, I submitted it. It's just letting me know that it was actually received, by the organization, and then I'm being notified that if there's anything more that I need to submit, that they would let me know, and I guess that's what then the files tab is for, if that happens.
Step 2, information gathering. So I guess this is a step where, if they do decide they need more information from me, that I would have to submit it, and again, I would use that Files tab to do that.
P09: Step 3…Oh, this is after they've received the supporting documents, but it's not so different than Step 2. Seems like they're reviewing the document and looking to see if there's anything more that's needed. And then finally, Step 4 is when they've made a decision on the application. And then I would be notified.
Moderator: Okay, thank you for walking through those steps. We just want to make sure we understand people's perception of those. So, now that you've kind of read through all these different pages and tabs, in your own words, can you tell me what you've learned about your application?
P09: So I've learned that I'm basically at the first step, that they just received the application, I must not have submitted it too long ago, and they're gonna notify me if I need to submit supporting documents.
Moderator: And what do you think will happen next with your application?
P09: I would expect to receive an email or a letter letting me know if I need to submit more documents to support the application, and if not, then I'll just wait to receive, an application decision.
Moderator: Okay.
Moderator: And is there anything else that you'd want to see or know about your application at this point?
P09: Well, I would say timeline. I think knowing the status, these steps, aren't that helpful as far as I imagine, the reason why people place these on websites is to give Veterans a sense that, okay, something is happening, and you're giving a sense that you're tracking where you are in your application, but, it doesn't really indicate timeline as far as how long before you're likely to receive a decision?
Moderator: Okay.
Moderator: So, you want to make sure that you know the steps, as well as how long steps will take, too. So what would you do next, if anything, at this point in time?
P09: After looking at this, I would say, okay, well, they received the application, I haven't heard anything. As it says here, that they might reach out to me, so I would leave this page, and then maybe go back to that original page and look at the other things that I have pending, now that I'm already logged into the website.
Moderator: I see. Okay. Well, that is good to know. So, let's pretend that you want to submit an updated marriage certificate for Jane Doe. What would you do?
P09: So I would go to the Files tab, and then I would click on Jane Doe, and then I would upload a scan of what I have of the marriage certificate there and then click submit files for review.
Moderator: Okay, so go ahead and click the file upload box, and we'll pretend that you just brought in a file from your device.
P09: The choose from folder?
Moderator: Yes.
P09: And then just select something.
P09: And then submit.
Moderator: Okay, so how was that process for you, and how does it compare to kind of what you were expecting to happen?
P09: I mean, so assuming those…
P09: I guess a little bit different, because I'm on my phone, and I wouldn't expect to have a copy of my marriage certificate on my phone. But if I did, and if that drop-down menu actually opened up a folder on my phone and allowed me to find it and click on it, I would say that it's pretty intuitive, and it's fairly convenient to do that.
Moderator: Okay.
Moderator: If you can scroll down on the page a little bit more, I would like your thoughts on what else that you see.
P09: So it looks like…
P09: each document I could do one at a time, and then I can continue to upload documents, either for Jane or John, which again is convenient that I could just click on their name and then upload another file. On the bottom, it's nice that it does show, files that I have submitted before, so it keeps track of that, so I don't have to second-guess whether it was received or whether I actually did submit certain documents. At the bottom, it says other ways to send your documents. Just looking at the headings, I would immediately kind of gloss over that. I mean, I don't ever expect to send anything by mail or by fax these days.
P09: And it says how to confirm we've received your documents. I think that's kind of interesting, because I assume that looking up here on the files received, that that is a confirmation that my documents have been received.
P09: But again, I wonder if this is for people who aren't ordinarily using their devices to submit documents, and maybe they get more peace of mind by actually talking to a person and letting them know that certain documents have been received.
Moderator: Okay.
Moderator: Thank you for walking through this page as well in some more detail. So, that is the end of our first scenario, so I'm gonna have you go ahead and go on to the next one. So, right there at the bottom of the screen, I know my video's kind of hovering over it, but there is a button that says proceed to the next scenario.
Moderator: Okay, so in this scenario, we're gonna say, let's, a week has passed since you, excuse me, a week has passed since, you just.
Moderator: I cannot talk this Friday afternoon. A week has passed and you want to find out what has happened with your CHAMPVA application. So, you log back in to VA.gov, and this upcoming screen is the first thing that you see. So, you can go ahead and click continue, and I want you to take a look at this page, and just tell me what you think has happened with your application.
P09: Okay, so I'm back at the page, I see that it's now at the top as opposed to the specially adapted housing one. It says in progress, but there's a yellow box that alerts me that actually may be needed. So, it makes me want to go inside and see what I need to do, which I expect probably has to do with needing to submit more documents.
Moderator: Okay. So you said that you would want to see, so what would you do next, then?
P09: So I'd click Check Status Details…
P09: And then I'll go down to see if it'll tell me what I need to do. So at the very top.
P09: It's actually, helpful, because the yellow does help draw my attention to it, because I don't have to search for what I need to do, and the box is at the top and tells me immediately what I need to submit. So I'd have to provide a copy of birth certificate.
P09: The phrasing of review request is a little bit odd. It's not what I would necessarily choose as far as what I think that's telling me to do, but it does look like I need to click on that link, though.
Moderator: What would you want it to say instead?
P09: Something like, to the effect… I know this might be too long, but submit requested document or something like that. That's what I think it's asking me to do, as opposed to review request. Review request sounds like you're having me review something that's already been done, or something like that.
Moderator: Okay. So, what would you do next, then?
P09: So I'd click on that, and I'm expecting it to give me an opportunity to upload that document.
P09: Hmm, but at the top, there's a dedicated page to birth certificates.
P09: That tells me what I need to do, so it says I need to upload John Doe Jr.'s birth certificate.
P09: Okay, so it says that I was actually given, as I said before, you know, VA oftentimes does send you things in the mail.
P09: still, and so it does say that. It's actually helpful, it tells me when that was sent.
P09: Next steps, if you have a copy of John Doe's birth certificate, it says, "if you have a copy".
P09: That raises a certain question in my mind.
P09: So, cause I'm thinking…you know, I don't have my birth certificate, what if I don't have a copy of John Doe Jr.'s birth certificate, so what do I do?
It presumes that I do have it, and that I can easily upload it. But it does say "if", so there must be something I can do if I happen to not have it, even though it's been requested. And then I see at the bottom it says, need help, so I assume if I don't have that certificate, then I would just call this number and see maybe why it's needed and if there are alternative documents I could send, or if they're just going to confirm, no, you have to just go get another birth certificate, and then upload that here.
Moderator: Okay.
Moderator: That's helpful context, and thank you for walking me through how you would, try to solve that problem. So what would you do next at this point?
P09: So I would go find John Doe Jr.'s birth certificate if I do have it.
P09: Scan it, probably just use my phone.
P09: And then, click Choose Folder.
P09: And then, yeah, assuming that I'd uploaded it, then I would click Submit File for Review.
Moderator: Okay.
Moderator: So, really quickly, before you click submit, how was this experience of uploading the birth certificate compared to uploading the marriage certificate?
P09: I would say it's just as simple, yeah.
Moderator: Yeah. And what were you expecting, going through this process and this experience of uploading it?
P09: I was expecting to be taken back to that original files tab. I thought it was just gonna take me to that generic files page and I would just upload a birth certificate there, but I was surprised that there was a dedicated page just for birth certificates.
P09: That actually indicate… I mean, I don't know if this will actually happen on the real page, where it tells you you need a copy of, and it says the name of the person, which is nice, it's very specific. And the fact that it actually tells me when a letter was sent to me, again, I don't know if you would actually implement something like that, but that's very specific to this.
P09: So yeah, it was nice to have a customized page that gives this kind of information, when all I expected was that files tab earlier, where I just upload whatever document was requested.
Moderator: Okay, thank you for that. So, which experience do you prefer, this dedicated page or the files tab?
P09: I'll say the dedicated page.
P09: And I like it, especially because it tells me when a letter was sent, so maybe I need to go look for that.
P09: Yeah.
Moderator: Okay, so it provides the date and some more information. So, okay, let's go ahead and scroll back down to the bottom and go ahead and submit the birth certificate.
Moderator: So, now take a look at this page and kind of tell me what you see.
P09: Okay, so green box, we received their certificate, so that's a confirmation that it did go through. And then…
P09: It actually indicates…
P09: My name and the two people that I'm submitting this application for. Status, here's the latest update on your application. It's in progress, that's the original application I submitted.
P09: We made a decision on part of your application on Jan 17. Keep reading for eligibility.
P09: Oh, okay, so I can see why something was asked for regarding John Doe Jr, because it looks like Jane Doe has already been enrolled in CHAMPVA. I assume in this situation that the Veteran going through this already knew that, that this was a surprise to me.
P09: What we're doing, step 3 or 4 information. We received the supporting documents to submit.
P09: I think it might be helpful here when it says information review, that it specifically speaks to John Doe's application, so that there's John Doe Jr.'s application, so that it's not confused with Jane Doe, who's already been enrolled. So if there's some way to differentiate that, that might be helpful for some folks.
Recent activity, this is kind of nice. It shows, all the different updates that have gone on recently.
P09: I think that's actually…
P09: More helpful than the outline of the steps that we saw earlier, because this is actually specific to my situation, and it gives me a better sense of progress, as opposed to the generic outline of steps. Not that having those earlier was a bad thing, but this is actually more informative.
Moderator: Okay.
Moderator: One of the things that you said earlier was, that a Veteran might expect this, or that you were a little bit confused. So, can you kind of talk through that again?
P09: On this page?
Moderator: Yes.
P09: Yeah, right here, it says Jane Doe's enrolled, I guess the first thing I said was, in this scenario, I didn't know that that was the case, so I'm assuming the Veteran going through this already knew that Jane Doe was enrolled.
P09: And I assume he or she must have been notified of that somehow via email or letter prior to this. But below that, it says what we're doing.
P09: We're at step 3 or 4 in information review. Now, I know that that has to do with John Doe Jr.'s application, because I knew that from before, information review, involves looking at supporting documents to see if he is eligible.
P09: If there's a way to differentiate John Doe Jr.'s application status progress from this information up here where it says Jane Doe's enrolled. That could be a little bit clearer for Veterans, because it's odd to see, oh, Jane Doe's enrolled, but what we're doing now is information review. Some people might just glance at that and think, oh, but if she's enrolled, what are they're doing about her application?
Moderator: I see, okay. So having it be distinct of Jane is at this step, John Doe Jr. is at this step, versus grouping them together.
P09: Right, and I don't know if it's because it's my the mobile sort of format of the webpage, but yeah, because it's directly below, it looks like, it could be one thing.
Moderator: Okay.
Moderator: And I'm… you had talked about, like, the recent activity was something that was really valuable. Can you talk a little bit more about that? I'm also curious, is this the place that you would like to see it on the page, or if there's somewhere else that you would like to see this information too?
P09: I mean, it is helpful, it could have been helpful if it was on an earlier page.
P09: Cause, it is interesting that that only pops up now after submitting the additional requested document. I'm wondering if it would have been better to be, to have been on the previous, like, the first page that we went into for this second exercise, yeah.
Moderator: Okay, so you want to see the activity a little bit earlier.
Moderator: Okay, so that is the end of our second scenario. So, to go to the last, I'm going to have you scroll to the bottom of the page, and then click that Proceed to the Next Scenario button.
Moderator: Okay. Okay, so now another week has passed since you've uploaded the requested documents. You want to go back in and check on your status for your CHAMPVA applications. So you've logged back into VA.gov, and this upcoming screen is the first thing you see. So I'm going to have you go ahead and click continue. So, take a look at this page again and then tell me what you see that's going on.
P09: So this is that first thing that I saw in the first scenario of the claim for especially adapted housing. Request to add or remove a dependent, is in progress, so I guess there must have been a request that was sent to add or remove a dependent.
P09: And I don't know if that has to do with adding John Doe Jr, or if now something has happened that I need to remove Jane Doe.
P09: It's a little curious to me as to what's decided as far as which box to be on top, because I remember the first time it was the specially adapted, and then the second time it was the CHAMPVA at the top, and now it's the specially adapted at the top, so I don't know if there's a rhyme or reason to that.
Moderator: What would you want the order to be?
P09: I don't know. I mean, the second one makes sense, because there was something that was being requested.
P09: Yeah, I'm just wondering if there is a rhyme or reason, whether it has to do with the timing of when the last thing was submitted?
P09: Now that I'm thinking about the scenarios, a week has passed, so I'm assuming this request to add or remove a dependent must have to do with the document that I sent for John Doe Jr, it might be helpful to have consistency in terms of the heading for that, I don't remember what the last thing said, but something to do with the CHAMPVA application, because this, the generic heading here, is not quite as clear.
Moderator: Okay.
Moderator: So what do you think has happened with your application for CHAMPVA then?
P09: It looks like it's Under initial review for…
P09: Sorry about that.
P09: Sorry, I'm gonna have to move rooms in a moment.
Moderator: You're fine.
P09: Yeah, so it looks like the document that I sent is still under review.
Moderator: Okay, so what would you do next, then?
P09: I would click on check status details, but I don't expect that there would be any more information than what I've already received.
Moderator: Okay.
Moderator: So, earlier, you mentioned the check, the track claims, decision reviews, and applications. What would you expect, again, to see if you were to click that link?
P09: The check track claims, decision reviews, and applications?
Moderator: Yes.
P09: To be honest, I don't know. At first, I assumed that it would be the same as check steps detailed...
P09: But, yeah, I'm not sure anymore, because it does speak to a greater a variety of activities like decision reviews, claims, and applications.
Moderator: Okay. Well, for today, let's go ahead and click on that link.
P09: Okay.
Moderator: So, take some time to review this page and just think out loud for me.
P09: Okay, so it's the status of claims, decision reviews, and applications.
P09: Manage and track the progress of certain claims decisions.
P09: Okay, so it indicates everything that's… oh, so it includes travel claims, too.
P09: So this is actually… I mean, basically everything. Like, any sort of, claims, so whether it's a health claim, travel claim.
P09: So I assume that the application for CHAMPVA would also be included in here as well, so I'm looking down.
P09: It says, your claims, decision, reviews, and applications in progress.
P09: I mean, so this is basically the same information as what was on that previous page?
P09: Download… so now download your letters, so this is if I wanted to submit any of these claims, it gives me information for that as well.
P09: If you can't find your claims to use your application, it might..
P09: So, I mean, so I feel like kind of a strange page for me, because at the top, at least, this is basically the same two boxes I see in the previous screen.
P09: And also, as with the original page that I was sent to, it already indicates, with more detail, all the different, claims that are in progress.
P09: Including, I think it was, like, education benefits or something, but I haven't looked at closed or all yet, so maybe the difference is that this indicates things that have been completed as well.
P09: But… I mean, the previous page was kind of similar, too, because at least it did say who was enrolled already in CHAMPVA benefits?
P09: So yeah, this does feel like a little bit of a redundancy here as well.
Moderator: Okay.
Moderator: Well, how does this compare to what you were expecting to find on this page, then?
Moderator: And across these different tabs, too.
P09: I don't know, I guess I thought based upon the heading or the name of the link, that there would be something more than what was provided in the previous page, but, if anything, it seems like it's much of the same information, but organized in a different fashion, which I guess if someone wanted to see these applications grouped into these categories of in progress and closed, that this would be the page for that. But I'm guessing as far as getting, like, status, information, it'll basically lead to the same information if I were to click on check status details here on this page.
Moderator: Okay.
Moderator: So with that, was your application for CHAMPVA benefits where you expected it to be?
P09: The application for CHAMPVA, but I mean as far as filling out the application, I don't know what that in itself entails. I'm assuming it'll be an online application, but when it comes to uploading supporting documentation.
P09: This seems fairly consistent with what I've seen as of late in recent years in terms of doing things online. I think the VA has been working towards making things more efficient and accessible as far as doing things via the app or on the webpage, so I would say it is consistent with that, so, I'm not too surprised.
Moderator: Okay.
Moderator: And what was the experience of finding the CHAMPVA application card itself, within closed.
P09: CHAMPVA card? You mean, like, this box right here?
Moderator: Yeah, so the boxes, so you see the claim for specially adapted housing, as well as request to add or remove a dependent. Where did you find your card for CHAMPVA?
P09: Where did I find it?
P09: You mean, like, are you asking how I feel about where it's located on the page, or…
Moderator: Yeah, so where is it located, and how do you feel about it being located there?
P09: Oh, so here, on this page, right now?
Moderator: For the box that says Application for CHAMPVA Benefits.
P09: Oh, the first time I saw that.
P09: On the, in that first scenario, that first page. Like, I would say, it was helpful that it was at the top.
P09: In the second scenario, it was having that yellow, box was helpful in drawing my attention to what was needed to be addressed. I would say for this one, I mean, the positioning isn't that much of an issue. It generally, all these things seem to generally float to the top anyways, things that are in progress.
P09: As I mentioned earlier, the only thing about this one is if it says something about CHAMPVA on this, as opposed to just request to add or remove a dependent, I think that would be more helpful.
Moderator: So, let me ask a quick question, then. So, here on the In Progress tab, you have the request to add or remove a dependent, and can you tell me what you feel is the difference between the box that is on the close tab?
P09: The box that's on the closed tab? Oh, here?
Moderator: Yes.
P09: Application for CHAMPVA benefits.
P09: Are you asking me what the difference is between?
Moderator: What, yeah, what do you think the difference is between the two?
P09: So this one is one that was already submitted, and the decision has been made, so no longer in progress, and so that's why it's under the closed tab. In progress, these are all things that are still pending, decision and under review.
P09: Yeah.
Moderator: So, what would have made it easier for you to find the box that said application for CHAMPVA benefits?
P09: If I wanted to… you're saying, if I wanted to see this box, what would make it easier for me to find this one?
Moderator: Yes.
P09: And I think where it is...I think it's fine. I mean, because if the scenario is I'm looking for the status on the one that's pending, then, it's good that in progress is actually, the first one that you see.
P09: Yeah, and this is fairly intuitive, too. I mean, just clicking on close, and I'm sure clicking all will show both in progress and closed ones.
P09: But, I think starting off with the page in progress actually makes sense.
Moderator: Okay. So, kind of based on the title of this page, how would you describe what this page is for?
P09: I mean, this… this seems like any sort of…
P09: I mean, basically anything I've submitted to the VA, looks like for travel claim, health benefits, education benefits, any sort of applications sent to the VA, this is the place to see where to find all of them, both ones that are in progress, as well as ones that have already been decided upon.
Moderator: Okay. So, what would you do next if you wanted to learn more about your application for CHAMPVA benefits?
P09: I would click on check status details of the request to add or remove a dependent.
Moderator: Okay.
Moderator: Okay, so for today, I'm gonna have you go back to the Close tab, and I'm gonna have you click Check Status Details of this application for a CHAMPVA benefits. So, now go ahead and review the page and kind of tell me what you see.
P09: Okay, so it says… Jane Doe is enrolled, but John Doe Jr. is not eligible.
P09: Okay.
P09: So… I'm assuming that I must have received a letter or an email or something already telling me that John Doe Jr. is not eligible for Benefits.
Moderator: Okay. And what would you do next, if anything?
P09: I would look for that letter that, I mean, if I was…
P09: I guess it depends on why I came to this website. If I came to this website to find out what the status of that decision was, and I saw this, then I would be wondering, okay, how come I didn't see this letter, and maybe I should go look back and see what the reasons are? And if the reasons aren't clear, then I would probably…
P09: Oh, well, it says here, if I disagree with the decision or have new evidence to submit. Oh you can request a decision review.
P09: I would do that if I wanted to continue to persist, and if I believe that he qualify for these benefits.
P09: Or maybe even call, call the number or send a message to ask VA.
Moderator: Okay.
Moderator: Well, that is the end of all of our scenarios for today, so thank you for walking through that with me. So you can go ahead and stop sharing your screen, but then I'll have a few more questions for you before we kind of finish up today.
P09: Sure
Moderator: So, can you tell me your overall impressions of this prototype?
P09: I think it's, I think it's good, I think it's… whoop.
Moderator: You got cut off for a second, go ahead.
P09: Yeah, something just popped up under Zoom.
P09: I would say, I think it's, it's easy to navigate for me, and having used a VA website before, it seems consistent with what I've been seeing. It's pretty straightforward, it's fairly clear. I think there are some, maybe, redundancies a little bit, in there. I don't know if, it doesn't hurt anything to have them. I'm not sure if some of those redundancies necessarily add much more to someone who's either, like, looking at the status of their application,Or wanting to see, previous decisions that were made.
P09: I kind of like, you know, more that I think about it, having all the statuses of all the things that I've submitted accessible on a single page, as opposed to just, like, seeing champ-based stuff, because I think that's… it's nice to be reminded of those things and not having to go to different pages for each thing that I've submitted.
P09: So yeah, overall, I would say it's good.
Moderator: Okay, thank you for that. So was there anything that was confusing or unexpected in the prototype?
P09: No, I mean, just some of the language that I'd mentioned, I think, could be more specific.
P09: And in that track claims, reviews, decisions? I mean, that page, again, still not 100% clear as to
P09: what more that adds to, I guess what's already presented in that original page, but…
P09: Apart from that, I think it's… I think it's good.
Moderator: Okay. And so, for this next section, I'm going to read 3 statements, and I would like you to rate them from how much you agree or disagree with each statement. So this is going to be on a scale of 1 to 5, where 1 means strongly disagree, and 5 means strongly agree. So, I thought the prototype was easy to use.
P09: The 5 is strongly agree, right? Yeah. 5.
Moderator: Okay, fine. I felt confident I understood what was happening with each person's application.
P09: I would say 4.
Moderator: Okay, can you tell me more, about that answer?
P09: It depends on how you define that, what's happening with the application. If I wanted to see the status, if I go there to click on the status, it doesn't necessarily…
P09: say what is happening. I mean, it's just… it basically says, wait… wait to hear from us if we need more supporting documents.
P09: So yeah, it doesn't necessarily tell you, like, at what stage you are in the process, but I… again, I don't think that's anything that the website can do to further provide that.
P09: And then also… The add or remove dependence box was still there alongside…
P09: another page that stated that the junior was no longer eligible, so having the two there… I mean, I don't know if it's just a matter of the scenario, that made it a little bit confusing to me.
Moderator: Okay.
Moderator: And then I knew where to look to find updates about my application.
P09: I would say 5.
Moderator: Okay.
Moderator: And then I know you've kind of given some feedback throughout, but overall, if you could wave a magic wand and change anything about the prototype or your overall experience after you've submitted an application for CHAMPVA, what would it be?
P09: Like, in a perfect world? In a perfect world.
Moderator: world, yeah.
P09: which, I know this would never happen, but if it was… if it was kind of like a, UPS tracking, where you actually have… see, like, where at what stage you are in, and you actually see the progress,
P09: That… and it gives you, like, an estimated time when things would arrive, so to speak. That would be nice to have something like that.
Moderator: Okay, so being able to see where you are in the process, as well as timeline for each of the things.
P09: Right, like a tracking bar that gives you a sense of how far you are in that. So it gives you, at least even if it's a false sense of progress, it gives you a sense of progress.
Moderator: Okay.
Moderator: Well, thank you for that feedback. So I'm gonna ask, do any of the observers have any questions?
Moderator: Okay, so silence, I'm going to take that as a no. So do you have any questions for me?
P09: No, I do not.
Moderator: Okay.
Moderator: So, with that, I want to circle back to the beginning, kind of reconfirm that you're comfortable if we share a video clip of the session with our VA partners. And again, just to remind you, we will remove all information that could be used to identify you before sharing, and we'll only share the videos with VA partners with the purpose of improving VA.gov and the digital experiences.
Moderator: So, are you okay if, we share a video clip?
P09: That's perfectly fine.
Moderator: Okay. Is there any part of the discussion you would not want to be shared?
P09: No, any of it is fine to share.
Moderator: Okay.
Moderator: So, well, with that, we really want to say thank you so much for taking your time today to share your thoughts with us. Your feedback has been very helpful, as we continue to work on improving the site and making sure that it really works for Veterans and their families. So, with that, thank you. And lastly, Perigean will be sending you a thank you note with a little blurb that you can pass along to other Veterans and family members you may know to provide them the chance to participate in future
Moderator: research studies. So with that, thank you again so much. I hope you enjoy the rest of your day, as well as have a great weekend.
P09: Thank you to you and to everyone in this room.
Moderator: Okay, thank you. Have a good one. Bye.